[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zur wahl des militär
des jahres schön dass sie wieder mit
dabei sind wir zeichnen angehörige des
österreichischen bundesheeres aus die
besonderes geleistet haben und zwar in
den kategorien rekrut des jahres
zivilbedienstete des jahres einheit des
jahres und soldat des jahres auch
special awards werden vergeben und das
werden wir in dieser folge tun
[Musik]
das team smn mobile entwickelt unter
enormem zeitdruck eine software die es
den bediensteten des österreichischen
bundesheeres erlaubt telearbeit mit
einer gesicherten anbindung zu
verrichten
der labor ihres untersuchungs und
inventur staffel ist es erstmals
weltweit gelungen eine runderneuerung
von munition durchzuführen dieser
vorgang schlägt sich mit einer
einsparung von neubeschaffungen in der
höhe von rund 20 millionen euro zu buche
details dazu gibt es jetzt von
generalstabschef general robert brieger
meine damen und herren ich freue mich
ihnen jetzt die gewinner der special
award vorstellen zu können
besondere zeiten erfordern immer wieder
besondere maßnahmen als das ausmaß der q
wie 19 pandemie erkannt wurde galt es
auch im österreichischen bundesheer
etliche hürden zu meistern
eine davon war die sicherstellung von
telearbeitsplätze
das team smn mobile musste unter enormen
zeitdruck dafür eine lösung finden eine
lösung die noch dazu den militärischen
sicherheitsvorschriften entspricht
bereits im juli 2020 wurden sieben
realisierungs varianten zur entscheidung
vorgelegt entschieden hat man sich für
sms mobile eine eigenentwicklung von
spezialisten des ekd und sauber
sicherheitszentrums die vollständig auf
software passiert und keine zusätzliche
hardware benötigt zeitgerecht im märz 20
21 wurde mit dem rollout begonnen
erwähnenswert dabei ist auch eine
einsparung von rund zehn millionen euro
ich gratuliere dem team smn mobile sehr
herzlich zum gewinn dieses special
awards
der pool ihren dem team smi mobile zum
special award
herzlichen dank
gratulation
[Musik]
der zweite special award geht an die
labors untersuchungs und inventur
staffel der harris munitionsanstalt groß
mittel die lagerung und kontrolle
laufende fehleranalysen brauchbarkeit
überprüfungen sowie die lückenlose
dokumentation aller technischen vorgaben
und wartungsmaßnahmen sind ein
anspruchsvolles tagesgeschäft
schaltpläne explosions pläne und
komplexe technische anweisungen
erfordern von den mitarbeitern ein hohes
maß an fachwissen technischem
verständnis und berufserfahrung dank
dieser parameter verbunden mit
akribischer arbeit ist es gelungen
rundum erneuerung und von munition
durchzuführen weltweit ist dieses
verfahren einmalig und daher ist der
gewinn eines special awards mehr als
verdient und dazu gratuliere ich sehr
herzlich
als kulant und blätter der heißen tanz
ein starkes mittel
erfüllt es mich mit besonderem stolz
ihnen diesen special award für
innovation zu überreichen
liz
wir alle gratulieren herzlich zu den
auszeichnungen mit den special awards in
der nächsten folge werden wir sehen wer
zur einheit des jahres gekürt wird ich
hoffe sie sind dann auch wieder mit
dabei
[Musik]